[Müzik]
merhaba Ben Deniz Dülgeroğlu Doktor
Deniz Dülgeroğlu bugün burada sizler
için bir TED konuşması yapmaya geldim
çok mutluyum açıkçası Çünkü hepimizin
bildiği üzere TED konuşması yapmak için
gerçekten toplum nezdinde çok başarılı
olan insanlar seçiliyor başarıya layık
görüldüğüm için gerçekten buraya
çağırdığımda müthiş bir Onur duydum ve
düşünmeye başladım ben acaba neden
başarılıyım diye
öncelikli olarak Ben bir doktorum bir
çene cerrahıyım Tabii ki bunun için çok
sağlam bir kariyer yapmam ve sağlam bir
eğitim almam gerekti gerçekten zeki bir
çocuktum 4 yaşında Okuma yazmayı
öğrendim 5 yaşında ilkokula başladım
ilkokuldan sonra Türkiye derecesi
yaparak Robert Koleji kazandım Robert
Koleji fen ve matematik alanında yüksek
derecelerle bitirip Türkiye'deki çoğu
üniversiteye tıplar dahil kazanıyor
olmama rağmen diş hekim çok istediğim
için Marmara Üniversitesi Diş Hekimliği
fakültesine birincilikle giriş yaptım
tabii ki Diş hekimliğini bitirdikten
sonra düz bir diş hekimi olarak
kalamazdım O yüzden Ağız Diş ve çene
cerrahisi alanında doktora yapmayı
seçtim
bunun sonucunda geldiğim yerde tabii ki
çok güzel bir statü elde ettim insanlar
bana gittiğim her yerde Doktor hanım
şeklinde hitap ediyor bakkala bile
girdiğimde hocam hoş geldiniz deniyor O
yüzden yaşadığım saygınlığı hissediyorum
ve tabii ki bunun sonucunda hayattaki
bir diğer başarı kriteri de para
Gerçekten güzel kazanıyorum yani size
şöyle söyleyeyim Bugün Bir implant
18.000 lirayla 20.000 lira arasında
sizin için Türkçe kura çevirdim
Türkiye'de kura da gerçekten euro ile
kazanıyorum bir hasta geldiğinde Mesela
bizim Total hastası dediğimiz tam dişsiz
Eskiden ağzına takma diş yaptıran bir
hasta bütün dişlerimi tek tek implant
yaptırmak istiyor modern çağda O yüzden
bir oturuşta bir Total hastasından ne
kadar kazandığımı
hesaplayabilirsiniz bunun da tabii ki
sonucunda Yani hafta sonları Ümraniye'ye
gitmek için minibüse biner gibi uçağa
atlayıp miami'ye gidiyorum
tasarım çantalar kullanıyorum sadece ve
boğaz manzaralı bir evim var Evimdeki
akıllı sistemimde tek düğmeyle suyun
sıcaklığında Ses sistemine ışıkları her
şeyi ayarlayabiliyorum ama lütfen böyle
konuştuğum için materyalist bir insan
olduğumu düşünmeyin Ben kesinlikle ve
kesinlikle mutluluğun sadece para ve
statüyle sahip olunabilecek bir şey
olduğunu düşünmüyorum mutlu bir evlilik
ve çocuk çok gerekli O yüzden bir erkek
arkadaşım var
şanslıyım yakışıklı ve annem de çok
beğeniyor kendisini gerçekten çok düzgün
bir insan ve
arkadaşlarımın hani sürekli tebrik
ettireceğinizden bir ilişki yaşıyoruz
Umarım darısı başımıza diyorlar Ben de
umarım Darısı sizin de başınıza olur
diyorum Allah herkese nasip eder
inşallah burada da isteyenler varsa
O yüzden genel olarak baktığımda şunu
görüyorum Gerçekten başarılı bir hayat
yaşıyorum o yüzden de bugün buraya Bu
başarının sırlarını sizinle paylaşmaya
geldim
[Alkış]
Evet 10 sene önce bu sahneye çağırsaydım
Muhtemelen Size bunları anlatıyor
olurdum
başarma sırlarını anlatıyor olurdum Ama
siz anlatmadığım çok başka Sırlarım
olurdu o yüzden onları Bugün anlatacağım
ben diş hekimliği fakültesini kendim
isteyerek seçmedim annem istedi Benim
için ben de okumaya başladım ama diş
hekimliğindeki her şeyden nefret ettim
ediyordum Ben bir kere beyaz renkten
nefret ederim ve diş hekimliğinde
dişlerden fayanslara beyaz önlükten
duvarlara floresan ışığına kadar her şey
beyaz Ben konuşmayı çok severim
gördüğünüz gibi buraya bir konuşma
yapmaya çağırıldım ve diş hekimliğinde
kimseyle konuşamıyorsunuz Çünkü
hastalarınızın ağzı açık sonra üzerine
bir de gittim çene cerrahisinde doktora
yaptım Eskiden hastaları En azından hani
Merhaba güle güle falan diyordum araya
şaka sıkıştırıyordum cerrahiye
girdiğimde artık anestezistin bayıltmış
şekilde getirdiği hastayı ameliyat edip
yine baygın şekilde çıkardığım için o
kadarında konuşamaz oldum tek duyduğum
şey şu oluyordu dıt dıt dıt bu makinenin
sesi
ve Diş Hekimliği hayatım boyunca bol bol
mobinge uğradım sürekli aşağılandım
hakaretler duydum Mesela bana bir Hocam
bu dövmelerinden hiç mi utanman yok
senin terbiyesiz şeklinde Profesör
Kendisi böyle bir söylemde bulunmuştu ve
ben bu mutsuzluğuma rağmen İnat ettim
devam ettim
ve çalışmaya devam ettikçe artık
dayanamadığım bir noktaya geldim en
sonunda
Strese bağlı anksiyete bozukluğu ve
yoğun bir depresyonun sahibi oldum ve
antidepresan ve kırmızı reçeteyle
sakinleştiriciler kullanmaya başladım
ama bunların hiçbiri yaşadığım hayatım
baskısını ortadan kaldırmaya yetmedi Ve
sonunda ben bir gece hayatımı
sonlandırmaya karar verdim ama korkmayın
burada olduğuma göre belli ki öyle bir
şey yaşanmadı Çünkü aldığım akademik
eğitimin ve bilimin bana tek bir katkısı
oldu o da hayata rasyonel bakmayı
öğrendim O yüzden dedim ki şu an Eğer
Kendimi öldürürsem bunun geri dönüşü yok
ama ölüme ertelersem ve birazcık
hayatımı değiştirmek gibi bir seçeneği
seçersem hayatımı sonlandırmak yerine
yine başarısız olursam en kötü doğalgaz
dedim kaçmıyor hiçbir yere ve o yüzden
Bıraktım Her Şeyi Geride erkek
arkadaşımdan ayrıldım çünkü hiçbir zaman
ona aşık olmamıştım anneme babamla tüm
ilişkimi kestim Çünkü Üzerimde acayip
bir baskı yaratıyorlardı beyaz önlüğümü
aynen bu şekilde fırlatıp attım ve bir
daha fakülteye hiç gitmedim ve o günden
sonra inanılmaz başarılara imza attım
şimdi sizinle bu başarılarımı paylaşmak
istiyorum birinci başarım kendimi
öldürmedim ve hayatta kaldım
hepinize tebrik ediyorum hala kendinizi
öldürmeyip hayatta kaldığınız için
gerçekten çok zor olduğunu düşünüyorum
özellikle yaşadığımız bu ortada
coğrafyasında
hayatta kalmak işin en zor kısmı
zannediyordum ama yaşamak kısmı daha da
zormuş bütün bu her şey geride
bıraktıktan sonra artık bir gelir
kaynağım olmadığı için ve kirada Bir
evim olduğu için geçinmek için yeni bir
iş yapmam gerekiyordu 26 yaşımda stajyer
reklam yazarı olarak bir ajansta
çalışmaya başladım o dönemin parasıyla
500 lira maaş alıyordum evimin kirası
1200 liraydı Teknik olarak evimde
oturmam imkansızdı O yüzden ben de kendi
kiralık Evimi kiraya vererek gizlice
ajansdaki hayatımı da Geceleri benim çok
işim var çıkamayacağım ses çıkın deyip
herkesin gitmesini bekleyip Ajans
masamdaki tek kişilik koltukta uyuyarak
yaşamaya başladım ama ondan sonra baktım
ki bu şekilde devam etmiyor benim bir
kanepeye ihtiyacım var yatmak için
ajansta bir sunum hazırladım koltuk
sunumu ve ajanstaki kratif direktörümü
eğer bir koltuk alırsak herkesin
muhabbet için önce koltuğa oturacağını
sonra geyik yaparken konunun işe
bağlanacağını ve sonuçta da elimizde
çözülemeyen bir bu lifi çözerek
kalkacağımıza inandırdım
IKEA'nın o dönemki en ucuz modeli olan
kılıfsız kulüp modeli alındı ajansa bu
sunumun sonunda ve ben ajanstaki
kanepede yatmaya başladım ama bazı başka
sorunlar ortaya çıktı mesela Duşun
içinde bir sürü temizlik malzemesi ve
temizlik kovaları vardı Her gece onların
hepsini tek tek boşaltıp yıkanıp tekrar
dizmem falan gerekiyordu O yüzden ben de
gittim
yakışıklı bir İngiliz çocuğa Evimi
kiraya verip sonra da çocukla sevgili
olup tekrar evimin içine kiracı olarak
girmeyi başardım
Merak etmeyin çocuğun aynı zamanda
aşıktım o kadar kötü biri değilim
onunla birlikte aynı evde yaşamaya
başladıktan sonra fark ettim ki hayatım
çok iyiye gitmiyor hızlıca Benim
meslekte yükselmeye başlamam ve iyi bir
kariyer yapmam lazım Çok çalışmaya
başladım ve çok çalışırken anksiyetem
geri döndü ben de o yüzden Terapiye
gidecek Param olmadığı için daha ucuz
bir olan O zamanlar daha ucuzdu En
azından gündüzleri şarap içmeye başladım
ve gitgide daha fazla şarap içtiğim için
ve üst üste üç kere Ajansı mutfağında
şarap içerken yakalandığım için
hayatımda ilk kez işten kovulmaya da
başardım
her seferinde alkışlamamıza gerek yok
çünkü çok fazla başarın var
ve ondan sonra baktım ki gerçekten şarap
içmeyi de bırakmam ve işe asılmam
gerekiyor Bu sefer gerçekten başardım
Türkiye içinde ve dünya çapında
birçoğunu gerçekten hala sadece benim
aldığım birçok ödülü kazanmayı başardım
çok iyi bir reklamcı oldum
ne yazık ki çok başarılı ve ondan sonra
bütün bu başarıların peşinde koşarken o
kadar çok sabahladım sabahlara kadar
çalıştım patronların bana küsmesin diye
her istediklerini yaptım ki başladığım
noktaya geri döndüm bir gece hastaneye
kaldırıldım geçirdiğim panik atak
yüzünden ve üç kere damar yolundan
sakinleştirici aldım en sonunda Doktor
daha fazla verirse tıbben tehlikeli
olduğu için sakinleştirici veremediğini
söyledi ve titreyerek bekledim sabaha
kadar ve o gece anladığım ki benim artık
reklamcılığı da bırakmam lazım
yapamıyorum
ve Döndüm başladığım yere
reklamcılığı bırakmak için paraya
ihtiyacım vardı ama reklamcılıkta pek de
para vermiyorlar aranıza reklamcı varsa
bilir o yüzden kenarda birikmiş 3
kuruşun bile yoktu o yüzden Türk
filmlerindeki o öleceğini öğrenince kötü
kadını oynayanlar gibi ajansa gitmeyerek
bir sürü seti yakarak
taarruz Murat almak için sadece
kovulmayı başardım yeniden ve aldığım
tazminatın parasıyla da Hayatıma yeniden
başladım
merdiven altı terapi diye bir Podcast
yapmaya başladım ve merdiven altı
terapide böyle birbirinden parlak
başarılarımı anlatıyorum işte
aldattığımı aldatıldığımı saç koparma
hastalığı mı yani böyle annenizin size
sakın orada burada anlatma diyeceği ne
varsa ben hepsini şu an yüzbinlerce
insana anlatıyorum Hatta o yüzden
düşündüm ki Daha önce podcaste
anlatmadığım bir başarı hikayemde burada
anlatayım size Ben spora gidiyorum 30
yaşından sonra vücudumuzu korumak için
tavsiye edilen bir şey
spora gittim geçenlerde yine spor
çıkışında da doktora gitmem Gerekiyordu
o spordan çıkıp koşturup koştur işte
metroya bindim çok susamıştım bir tane
su aldım Ondan sonra metroya bindim
doktorun olduğu yere vardım Doktora da
şimdi arkadaşım eli boş gidilmez diye
bir tane pastane vardı pastaneye girdim
işte oradan böyle kap kek falan havalı
birkaç böyle bir şey bir kutu dizdim
kendime de bir tane kahve aldım Gittim
doktora
Doktorda ne yapıyorsun derseniz işte
yine 30 yaş üstü bir yüreğim ilgilendiği
şeyler
glutatyon işte vitamin C vitamin ve
mineraller ne kadar eksik varsa ki ben
tost yapmak dışında hiçbir şey
pişiremeyen bir insan olduğum için çok
eksiğim var kanımda bunların hepsini
gidip böyle düzenli aralıklarla damar
yolundan alıyorum iki tane serum yaptı
bana Doktorum gidip eve bir tane yeni
Podcast da hazırlamam lazımdı O yüzden
alelacele çıktım tekrar metroya bindim
metroya bindiğimde hafif hafif Çişim
gelmeye başladı Allah Allah dedim ya
aslında o kadar da bir şey içmedim sonra
hesaplamaya başladım içtiklerimi bir
tane su içmişim yarım litre Ondan sonra
sadece 6 lira farklı orta boy kahve
ister misiniz dedikleri için bir tane
orta boy kahve almışım O da yarım litre
arkadaşım 2 tane serum taktı her serum
500'er 1 litreden yani yarımşar litreden
1 litre 2 litre ediyor toplam ve
zamanında anatomi derslerini başarıyla
bitirmiş bir insan olarak size
söyleyebilirim ki bir kadının sidik
kesesinin maksimum kapasitesi 800
mililitre 2 litre sıvıyı vücudumuzda
tutmanız mümkün değil
metrodan çıktığım gibi bu şekilde
tuvalet aramaya başladım
insanlara sormaya başladım Çünkü Google
maps'te yazmıyor nerede olduğu ve Türk
insanında muhteşem bir huyu var
biliyorsunuz asla bilmiyorum demez ilk
sorduğum kişi bana tuvalet solda dedi ve
tuvalet solda değildi bir sonraki sağa
dön koridorun sonunda dedi oraya gittim
tuvalet orada da değildi en sonuncusu
Buradan git git git git git git git dedi
uzun koridorun sonunda turnikelerden
sola dönün dedi orada karşına çıkacak
bütün O yola gittim ve karşıma Büfe
vardı Ve artık dayanma imkansızdı Yani
iki seçeneğim vardı bu projenin
Gözlerinin içine baka baka 2 litre
sıvıyı aşağıya salmaya başladım ve hani
böyle altıma küçük bir kaçırmaktan
bahsetmiyorum bileklerime kadar işedim
ve ondan sonra arkamı döndüm ve kadınlar
tuvaletini gördüm
üzerimde spordan çıktığım için lila
renkli bir tayt vardı ve idrarın çizdiği
bütün yol böyle burada görünüyordu O
yüzden ben de bari artık Battı balık yan
gider deyip lavaboyu açtım önce sağ
bacağımı sonra sol bacağımı lavaboya
sokarak bütün taytı ıslattım ve kış
soğukluğunda Dona Dona evime bu şekilde
gittim
Yani ben 36 yaşında altıma işemeye de
başardım
ama daha da güzeli bugün şimdi altıma
işeme hikayemi burada size anlatmayı da
başardım Çünkü bana soracak olursanız
artık başarı ne diye Bence toplum bütün
düşüncelerinin canı cehenneme onların
gözünde başarılı olmak istiyorsanız
gerçekten gecenin sonunda hastaneye
gidip işte tıbben tehlikeli seviyelerde
sakinleştirici almanız gerekiyor bazen
ama Bütün bunların hepsini utanılmayacak
şeyler olduğunu fark ederseniz sonunda
özgürleşmeye ve kendiniz olmaya
başlıyorsunuz Evet şu an çok havalı bir
kartvizitim yok ve gerçekten Boğaz
manzaralı bir evin sahibi olamadım ama
gerçekten bir büyük evvel bu kadar
şarkısını dediği gibi mutsuzum Ama
keyfim yerinde
konuşmama dönecek olursam
diyorlar ki başarılı bir TED konuşması
Şöyle anlaşılıyormuş konuşma bittiğinde
seyircinin aklında tek bir cümleyle
çıkması gerekiyormuş O yüzden çok
başarılı bir insan olduğum için ben bu
cümleyi de sizin yerinize hazırladım
Bundan sonra ne zaman kendinize eksik
yetersiz hissederseniz başarısız
olmaktan kaygı duyarsanız şunu
hatırlayın lütfen 2023 senesinde
Bursa'da altına işemiş bir kadını
başarılı buldukları için bin kişinin
karşısına çıkarıp bir TED konuşması
yaptırdılar
[Alkış]